all righty so I'm gonna sing us in
because I moved houses as you can see
behind me new new office and uh I don't
know where my guitar is it's supposed to
be somewhere in this um but anyways
welcome back to the corner digital
podcast it's been a minute uh thanks for
watching um I've got some very special
people here today including but not
limited to Jordan Allen why is he first
yeah I'm here I totally thought it was
going to be me I totally went for you I
totally went for Jordan Allen because I
saw JC starting to wave
um no I'm just trying to stir the pot
between the Jordans we've got both
Jordans today Jordan Coleman's with us
so really they're not that special
because they both have the same name
and of course mean dean with a mean dean
comment right there right off the bat
especially taking it off very special
stop it
um how are you doing how's everybody
doing it's lovely yeah chilling yeah I'm
like equal parts hot and cold in here
and I'm not sure what that means for me
yeah yeah you know you'll adjust thank
you Jordan Coleman recently painted the
green screen and somebody wrote over
with a one wheel this morning it could
have been Sam's bike too could have been
deemed uh actually yeah it was probably
Sam although unless it was was a thin
pass
it was definitely in one wheel did you
see those tread marks well then it could
have only been run
I carried mine in look at you hunting
for the killer Nick came into audacious
I mean Ren it was painted for Ren and
then
at the end of the day either way I'm not
shocked yeah it happens I mean we can't
even go 12 hours with something nice
you know what does that say about us I
really do think the green screen so for
people don't know our studio floor now
is painted on the ground with a big
green screen but it's yes literally just
paint there's no there's no border so
like people just walk in and walk right
over it and over time it gets super
dirty I think we need just a slightly
raised border around it yeah but then
just a little back maybe one that can go
that way when you have like a special
guest in when you get like JJ Abrams in
he like trips over it and like Falls you
know and then he has a story that's the
kind of awkward introduction that we
really need to solidify in the studio
you know yeah but you know it is what it
is yeah I noticed that they're always
trying to make some like a new thing to
help the thing that could just be done
you know it's like instead of people
just not walking on it we're like what
could we do to make people not walk on
it and it's just like well the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over and expecting
different results why do you keep
painting it
yeah I just read it and so I it's real
because anything that got written is
real yeah
someone write that down here's an idea
here's an idea we could do invisible
fencing and everyone could wear a shock
collar oh
yeah
that's totally illegal yeah you can sign
you can sign a waiver for that
would be hilarious yeah like pretend
you're signing up for something else and
have them sign off for sure yeah hey
guys we're gonna go play paintball I
need everyone to sign this death waiver
real quick
you can have a live stream on the shot
yeah just on the security camera here
shock cam
people can have a light in their like
bedroom and it can goes red whenever
someone's getting shocked we can all run
down to see yes it just it just goes
yeah it's like yeah he's riding in pain
yeah
look at that loser uh
oh man all right well so today's topic
um it's it's it could get hot I don't
know if it will or not it totally can
I'm totally fine with that uh but I'm
doing a bit of research right now
um some initial research I'm not super
super deep yet um but I'm doing some
initial research on the legality of and
consequences of The Tick Tock ban
obviously you may have heard this is a
Hot Topic right now in uh the US
Congress and um a bill was introduced at
the beginning of the month of March and
I believe they are now
debating over that
um and so I wanted to talk in more
general terms you know uh what what the
hell is this you know and and what does
it mean because I'm I'm sort of putting
out feelers and I wanted to use you all
as my you know experimental guinea pigs
to bring up certain topics that I might
want to address during the lawyer
explains video I mean words so gen Zone
don't do that don't do that there's like
45. don't do that that's rude
or some [__] yeah
so that's the problem
um Jake maybe you could give me an
overview because I don't take and or
talk what is this bill well okay so
here's the gist of it okay
um
the uh Tick Tock is is a subsidiary of
it's a wholly owned subsidiary but it's
it's independent of the it's it's a
parent Corporation bite dance
uh bite dance is a Chinese Corporation
and uh as part of the laws of in the
land of China
um one of the sort of stipulations uh if
you will is simply that
um any company uh has to report to the
CCP that the this communist Chinese
Communist party uh for whatever
information they might want or need
um I believe there's other stipulations
such as uh certain companies of certain
sizes must have a party member on their
executive board
um and things like that so obviously I'm
this I don't want this to become some
like xenophobic thing about China I just
mean to point out
um that there are they do things a heck
of a lot differently over there and
um there's sort of this General concern
which is you know 150 million Americans
use this app and uh at any given point
in time uh the concern is that the data
that's being generally collected from
the use of the app can be turned over at
a metadata level and given to uh you
know what what might be for nefarious
purposes for an external foreign
government to manipulate and to uh
meddle with the the experiment that is
America so that's the idea and now
there's been bills proposed which are
supported by both parties uh pretty
heavily supported by both parties uh to
to put a ban to this now we can get into
the
all the other implications of the bill
um which has not been finalized or
anything yet uh but that's that's the
general the general idea and of course
as you might expect all the other big
tech companies in the U.S side are
heavily in favor of this because of
course why wouldn't they be yeah you
know it's like an enemy of my enemy is
my friend sort of thing where they're
like
it if they go away then all that market
share opens up for the big tech
companies and of course there's there's
many arguments that that can be made
about this
um but I kind of wanted to open it up
for discussion and see what kind of
issues we naturally find ourselves on to
help inform me as I sort of develop this
Pathway to put out a video for
explaining to people in more concrete
terms and legal terms what's actually
going on because it's hard to find good
information out there and that's one
thing I noticed when I did the AI videos
it was nice to just put out a solid
piece of information that people could
go okay this breaks it down
in layman's terms and you understand the
implications and the legal consequences
so
that's where I'm at
yeah I would say as an American
the only people who get to bulk collect
my metadata is the National Security
Agency
let's talk about the arguments on both
sides of that the first argument is like
exactly that well every tech company
steals your data right so why does it
any different if bite dance does it
versus meta
and that's you know the the the argument
against that as I've heard is simply
just this well at least they're beholden
to some form of democratic process here
those at least
yeah we can we can bring them before
Congress we can have hearings we can you
know work with our the people's house
which is the House of Representatives to
instill Representatives who might you
know be more favorable to our interests
but then um they the NSA will
take that data from those companies and
then go in front of Congress in light
that they didn't take that yes right so
so
I can't really I haven't been able to
pinpoint this in the bill yet
um this might be all talk but there's
been some discussion that effectively
this entire bill
I've heard it equivalent equivalated is
that a word equivalated
I'll use it I like that we know what you
mean that's what language equivalent
arguments have been made to the it's
like a it's like a 2023 version of the
Patriot Act and oh yeah I'm trying to
find out the specifics of where that is
in the bill because it says things like
you know effectively this entire
decision will be turned over to the
executive branch which is exactly what
happened with the Patriot Act and why we
have such a
uh in my opinion egregiously overdone
secure like National Security sort of
War industrial complex going on
currently because when the Patriot Act
happened I won't get too deep into that
but when that happened
effectively we turned over all of these
tools and powers and abilities from
Congress which is where the people get a
vote to the executive branch which is
you get one vote for one guy every four
years and it's always a bad choice so
you know and then it's like he gets to
do whatever he wants with all of the
Departments and all the money that
Congress has now given over authority to
and this has been happening for a long
time it didn't just start with the
patreon and that like trickles down to
little bureaucrats and eventually
exactly who's like on his computer like
spying on his ex-girlfriend with this
information yeah unfortunately that's
that's probably happened
um but so that's that's also like a
legitimate concern too is is if you turn
over we continue to turn over more and
more power to the executive branch to
sort of execute the people's will if you
will
then you know where does that leave us
um that's that's another huge concern
I don't know that I don't know that
people having are being beholden to
going in front of Congress really does
much for me
like having having seen them interview
Tech Giants oh yeah they don't know what
they're talking about yeah that's it's
like a waste and there always seems to
be a loophole like there's always yeah
and then like everyone just forgets that
it never even yeah like the yeah the the
Facebook hearings was it's some of the
funniest stuff ever because you have
like some great it's so meanable it's
like older than my grandparents being
like how do you make money on Facebook
and he's like sir we run Senator we run
ads and the guy's like what's an ad
newspaper yeah I mean there were some
pretty uh there were some pretty good
quips from the um they inter they they
set the uh
CEO of uh Tick Tock uh who's a I believe
he's Singaporean
before the uh you the Congress and one
of the questions was does tick tock
connect to your home Wi-Fi
it's like they know the hot words and
they just don't know what they they
don't know they don't know what order
[Laughter]
how'd you get on the whiffy
uh I don't know yeah I'm more shocked
that 150 million people we're talking
active users of tick tock yes in America
it's completely captured like young
people's attention and it's like I'm
sure people set up on Facebook and stuff
but it's like this algorithm is
different I and I've seen
adults spend
seven eight hours a day on Tick Tock
especially during uh quarantine it was
like that yeah they perfectly timed that
that's not a cons that I'm not that's
not
fiercely but it's it is like something I
think you need to take note of that it's
like well okay yeah there was a lot of
stuff like a lot of tech platforms that
came out at the time that were just like
because I feel like covid kind of
emphasized a lot of trends that were
already happening in our culture like
yeah
gig economy you know people
um yeah surfing social media all the
time and uh yeah I feel like Tick Tock
is like I think I've said this on the
podcast before but it's like the closest
equivalent to a slot machine I've ever
seen for social media because yeah like
new information to our brain that's just
a dopamine pop is like you know you
scroll through for me it's like
Instagram is the one social media
platform that I use so I scroll through
sometimes I'm not even like I'm not even
thinking I'm just like you know like oh
could do colors you know I removed I
removed Instagram from my home page for
that exact reason I
um I I so I put it in like the back of
my apps so that when I go there it's
like okay I have to like go through my
phone to get to it you know it's fine
I've done the same thing
yeah I've done I've done all I put it on
a different page put it in two two
folders within folders now it's just
muscle memory I open my phone
do the move to get there dude have you
ever have you ever closed it and then
opened it yes that's the worst one like
when you're like all right I'm gonna get
off this and then you're just back on it
you're like what oh I'm happy that at
least we all share that oh yeah 100 yeah
right it's and that's so and I feel like
Instagram is pretty
I don't know I feel like Instagram is
the lightest offender you know I find
Twitter is a place where people go to
like destroy their mental health yeah
and Facebook is just for old people now
essentially in my opinion yeah
um sorry I know you're a big Facebook
like connecting with the people you went
to like high school with and stuff it's
like not for people that you're
currently friends with it's like Grandma
and Grandpa and then like oh let's see
what Kate from like junior year of high
school's up to sure oh another kid okay
cool let me get off yeah I don't know
but tick tock tick tock was the one
where I
through the line where I was like I am
an adult now I can't keep up with the
kids so I'm not gonna try yeah
my biggest issue and the regulation with
Tick Tock and that we allowed um young
kids on it because there's nothing I
think there's some time restraints on
there but like whatever a 35 year old
man can see your 11 year old daughter
can see you and vice versa and like
there's girls being over sexualized too
early there's so much happening and
there's all these little kids that
already have so much anxiety and
depression from video games and then
they're just that dopamine hit and
they're just seeing all of this stuff
that's just coming to them and then
they're acting out in school and they're
they're acting completely insane and
like parents are like oh but they're
just a boy and I'm like no it is all
coming from these social media platforms
and even the way that the kids play
video games like fortnite yeah oh my God
these kids they are are angry they're
angry and their anxieties to the roof
and they're getting more depressed yeah
when uh I think it's interesting to
think about when did you guys get social
media like what age were you when it
became a thing at like your schools my
space but my mom didn't let me on it
until like
sometime in high school like all my
friends are on it in middle school and I
think I wasn't allowed until high school
but then it was highly like regulated
like my mom had my password to
everything and like there's like
back then I was like and this is prison
yeah you know
today like there wasn't a way to connect
to so many types of people all around
the world and I don't know yeah it's
it's kind of really really scary yeah
but so it was high school what about you
I started my MySpace page in my early
30s
no no
um for me all through high school that
was like when it was just emerging
Myspace was a thing and I had my you
know the top eight and customizing your
customizing your page like in making it
just hideous
um but I didn't have a phone a lot of my
peers had the phones a little slide in
text phones uh but I the day I got mine
I put in the washing machine on accident
and my mom's like well that's your phone
for two years and so I just didn't have
a phone yeah so I never grew like
accustomed to yeah constantly being
available to everybody and I kind of
carry that through to now which I'm very
very grateful of yeah uh because even my
feed like on Instagram Instagram's
probably my biggest uh addiction I'd say
but even that I only really follow
people who are producing content that is
like stimulating to me as a visual
effect so inspiring yeah yeah and that
gets me off it a little faster but even
then I find myself pulling the the
little slots wheel yeah and the
Instagram algorithms to the explore page
which is like their version of kind of
that Tick Tock discover
when we were growing up our phones
didn't have everything on it like the
internet capabilities just weren't there
so like if you did want to go on to
Myspace it was when you finally got home
you know and it's just like I only have
this many options but now it's just I
can record anything I can do anything at
any point in time and upload it and now
kids at eight seven have iPhones so they
have the exam exam technology that like
I said a 35 year old man does yeah and
we're all in the same place the brains
are like mush that's the thing is the
attention span yeah oh my gosh mine has
gotten so much worse since the Advent of
all this stuff and I I actively gauge it
and try to like cut myself off yeah so
if you don't I mean I I know you know
yeah not only do you not but it's like
if you're eight and your brain is like
not even halfway done forming and you
have not even you have a phone with
social media on it your brain is is just
forming around that as a as a way of
being in in the world and it's like I
don't know well on that note The Tick
Tock see they asked and they're like do
your kids use tick dog he's like no
no and they're like yeah what is it the
dealer doesn't use their own products
but also like in China the way Tick Tock
is regulated is much different the
things that are accessible to them when
they're scrolling it looks way different
yeah you know so it's that that's
another thing too like when Jake I'm
sure you when you're gonna start finding
like
because of the way our laws are made
here it's like Tick Tock could never be
the same as China because
our our laws are just different like we
can't over regulate in too many ways
because then you the the freedom that
damn democracy you know so it's like
where do you draw the line democracy out
of the way if you think we could be more
like China yeah
well you know it's like Bolton just ban
it I guess because we can't
yeah so okay so on that note here's
here's another argument that I've been
reading about if so Tick Tock uh sorry
sorry U.S based social media platforms
YouTube what have you they're banned in
China
right
I
can't say with absolute certainty but I
know for a fact YouTube is and I I think
you know take one with the other I I'm
pretty sure it is
um although a lot of people will use
vpns over there to get access right
using a VPN is illegal over there no
yeah I know but I mean uh it's not yeah
I mean obviously on the like we're
talking policy side like obviously China
has no freedom of speech and no right
right but my point is those are those
are banned over there to stop the
influence external influence into
Chinese culture and look one thing I
want to be clear about I'm all about
National sovereignty if if the if the
nation decides they want to run their
lives a certain way they you know 100
that's that's the way that that's the
way that it works
um but
should we also consider if okay if these
are banned over there
should we ban their versions over here
and of course the argument is well does
that make us any better to to ban them
here if if if we do that
um you know the real Crux of it I think
comes down to this what you're saying
about the First Amendment uh and it's
beyond that but it's this idea that
there's this somehow I don't know how we
really got here but there's this idea
that freedom comes with the ability to
do whatever you want
at all right
ultimate uninhibited freedom
and there's no consideration for like
the responsibility
that it comes with um
it's like if if you're going to be given
ultimate freedom and you have no sense
of morality or uh like work ethic or
responsibility you'll just become a
tyrant
you become a tyrant to other people
around you
if you're given freedom and you craft it
and you build it and you you then you
become you know like a noble King in
that way where you can you know
do something better with it and that's
that's the idea but you can't
legislate for that
you can't yeah you can't like force it
into people you have to
you have to build it yeah so and I feel
like you can't like Tick Tock You Can't
Ban it just on the on the grounds of
like
the effect it's having on on people
because like you're saying it just comes
down to like everything in the past it
comes down to parents yeah being able to
like so many players that's a huge part
of it yeah
um well I mean didn't they uh didn't
they ban
I don't know how to say it is it Huawei
or the oh yeah Huawei yeah the Chinese
phones because they were worried that it
was
I mean essentially listening in and they
were gathering data that way how
different is this data Gathering because
it's consensual I guess but can a kid
consent to giving away information I
that's where it gets grayer to me is
yeah is it more nefarious than that like
they're worried that oh it's it's
monitoring us beyond what they're saying
or it's just that 150 million people and
a bunch of like
it's a it's a social media platform
Huawei was not a social media platform
Huawei was a hardware infrastructure
yeah that that we said hey we don't want
you guys building our phone lines and
building our internet connections in
this country because we don't know the
implications of that and of course again
on this idea of national sovereignty and
I want to point out I I like we
oftentimes I do feel like there's a
common thing that we do as Americans
which is we we we totally allow and
understand and are respectful of like
the sovereignty and the decisions that
people make outside of this but then we
expect ourselves to not be able to make
those decisions for ourselves as well uh
how do you mean like uh for Huawei for
example you know like
um if if say Canada wanted to use only
Canadian companies to build their
infrastructure for their phones everyone
would look at that and go yeah that
makes sense they're they're their own
country and and they should be able to
do that but when you you do that here
and oftentimes there's backlash it's
like well what do you you know what are
you preventing
um or what are you trying to prevent
um you know and it often goes to this
like will stop being uh you know
reclusive and xenophobic and scared of
other cultures you know you should be
open to other cultures because that's
obviously one of the tenets of uh of our
culture
um why do you think that happens more
here than in other places it was kind of
it became really clear at the beginning
of covid when there was all of these
medicines that were like only made in in
China that we when all the global Supply
chains shut down and we didn't have
access to it it's like oh we should
probably make some of that stuff here in
case that happens you know and that's
yeah specifically about China it's just
like the fact that we don't make
anything anymore yeah and I think that's
that's kind of yeah that's kind of like
a key tenet of any Sovereign Nation you
you have to be able to hold your own and
uh produce for yourself when you need to
and when you when you give away all of
those abilities to other places well
then now you are beholden to those
places
to to maintain your way of life and
that's been going on here for a really
long time not just with social media or
with you know whatever like for a really
long time
um and some of that has been good it's
brought you know a an increase of
overall wealth for the average
individual it's brought the like
immediacy of cheap and available
products and food
but uh it's
I I think the real question is like has
it gone too far
have we gone too far down that road you
know like we don't have skillful workers
I feel like we just it's kind of like
you know the other day we booted up um
there's a new AI texted video that we
brewed up yeah the other day and we were
just looking at it in absolute uh
excitement and Terror uh the journey one
or was it a different one no so it's uh
it's called I'm forgetting the name but
it's um built into the stable diffusion
interface that we that we use okay but
it's like you know you type in text
Vin Diesel eating a bowl of pasta and a
video a video of Vin Diesel eating a
bowl of pasta that's what I've always
wanted it doesn't look great but I've
always yeah I saw the I saw the uh
render or whatever you want to call it
it doesn't it's like you know it doesn't
look great but it looks about as good as
like mid Journey one looked last year
early last year when we were playing
with it and we were like oh it's cute I
was like this might be something in like
10 years and then a year later it's like
completely changing how we do things
um
the point there is that
we are like
we're just kind of on this path and I
don't think there's any veering off this
path what Tick Tock no
the the way the Glo the world is
changing the interconnectedness it's
like
where it's oh yeah
interconnectivity is an important
element that we need to utilize it's
like a tool that we've spent the
previous
all of humanity getting to
and now but now we're at a point where
we need to
as we were at all the other points
before that we need to appropriately
navigate through this yeah so that when
we come out the other side
the tools are functional and good and
useful and improve people's lives
without becoming something that nobody
intended them to be and that just
requires
thinking about it and it requires
what you know it's like a little bit of
mindfulness honestly yeah and I think
but the only thing we can fight for is
democracy is like democracy and
transparency there's like challenging
governments to be like open about what
they're doing and to open up the
decision-making process to the people
and uh like that's all we can do like
that's what they're doing in France
right now like they they change the
right right uh what was it Social
Security their version of Social
Security pension yeah they made yep they
made some changes where it's now you
need to be five years older I believe
than it was before and some other
changes and people are not happy about
that I know how
I know the French like to take their
time off you know yeah
I'm just I'm just kidding that's just a
dig that's just a nasty dig people hit
the streets you know and like that's
yeah
like if things get out of whack I mean
that's what we got to do but
I think at least the technology side
we just have to figure out how we're
gonna live with it yeah and like here's
on that note Dean the idea of
maintaining transparency and democracy
which are some of the most important
tenets of our culture
I am almost so
I would rather if this if this bill
that they are they're certainly going to
introduce a bill at this point if this
bill comes with this idea that we take
an incredibly Broad
stroke at all of
social media and applications and
Platforms in their entirety and we
relinquish the ability to decide who
gets to stay and who must go to the
executive branch of the federal
government I am so much more against
that than I am against a particular
platform
yeah like we we just can't uh in my
opinion we just can't allow any more of
that like we've we've given so much to
the federal authorities
to make decisions in all kinds of these
nuanced ways that
have they have no no ability or
competency to be able to be doing and
this should be happening at the local
level or at least at the state level uh
that's honestly that's more my concern
than whether or not kids are watching
Tick Tock and I know that there's a huge
inherent problem with the consumption of
that as it is but that's what I'm trying
to say like my concern for that for
giving more authority over to the
executive in a huge broad Strokes way is
I think way more dangerous in the long
run than a particular app and I think
the framing of it uh I think it's an app
comparison to the Patriot Act because
it's Being Framed as like Hey we're
stopping the Chinese from getting in our
business but really it's like we're just
increasing the ability of the government
to kind of control what you consume and
right it's like that government's a big
Corporation and it's gonna if you give
it more power it's gonna it's gonna oh
yeah give me some more of that I got I
got I got Mouse to feed I got friends to
pay I got
yeah and and look I don't mean to say
that it doesn't have its useful
purpose in our society I'm not like some
like everyone always pigs me on this
platform as like some like
neo-libertarian like crazy guy who just
doesn't want anyone to tell anybody
anything ever it's like I don't know why
they get that I just but anyways because
you live in Texas
because I live in Texas yeah that's why
um
libertarian crazy
I mean there's plenty of them here but
yeah
um but yeah anyway yeah my point is like
I don't mean to confuse that this
conversation with this idea that like
there's a useful place and purpose for
self-governance and people to be a part
of that and and to contribute to it and
for it to influence people's lives in
certain ways I just I just think it's
been it's so it's gotten so far beyond
what it was intended to do that you know
now we're at this place where uh the
21st century is going to be interesting
man I mean we're already almost a
quarter way through it but you know like
you know with everything we've seen in
the last 23 years with basically the
dawn of social media the next 20 23
years is 25 years is going to be the
period where we figure out
how to appropriately manage those things
so that the next 50 years hopefully
instead of being war and famine is
prosper and knowledge and people growing
new skill sets and taking Humanity
further yeah that's what's going to be a
little squirrely on the way there though
yeah yeah you have a lot of greedy
people who are in power yeah and they're
not making laws for the for the greater
good of anyone really you know like
unfortunately here's an interesting
thing on that so they they there was
this movement recently to try to ban
um Congress people from uh investing in
stocks while they were in office which
is a pretty
effing reasonable yeah
and guess what no died no totally died
immediately yeah Dylan totally died
in there she's 100 million she's she's
more than that yeah multi-hundred years
but she's just a nine figure Jake
Investments dude it's she's like that
one that one is one we can all get
behind yeah like that's an easy just
please if you're gonna be in the
people's house yeah or if you're gonna
be in the Senate you don't get to hold
stocks yeah that's a layout put them
into a Vanguard fund and set them away
for the two years that you're before you
know or whatever or the rest well that's
okay but that's your career politician
like that's the thing
um so yeah that's that one to me is one
that's just so inherently obvious and
that one more particularly than almost
even The Tick Tock band shows the
inherent hypocrisy of the whole thing
it's like well we can't do that I mean
well we can't do that for us we we need
to be able to trade stocks before the
bills get passed and that's come on how
else would be
I think that's kind of the thing behind
it too and where I immediately default
to not doing not giving the government
really anything because
there's at the end of the day you know
it's like I don't inherently believe
that oh these people are the ones I
should trust like they've given me no
reason to believe that you know no
they're human beings they're human
they're human beings and it's a human
institution and the only thing that
makes it higher than a Human Institution
are the laws themselves
and as soon as we don't adhere to the
laws themselves
we we immediately adhere to whoever that
become that's where you go to tyranny
that's where you go down the road of now
it's he says she says and whatever who's
in power goes
rather than now the law becomes
equivalent to the person who wields it
rather than above the person
and I think that that that corrupts the
entire idea of free western Society yeah
I mean when it comes to who's running
for office in the first place I've
always felt it a bit strange of like who
would want to have these positions
through you know helping and taking on
like essentially like a small salary for
taking these positions of course is
going to be the people who are power
hungry it's going to attract this very
type of people that you don't want to
take it and the people who you do want
will likely pursue other Ventures it's
like CEOs of Corporations like I feel
like you kind of have to be a sociopath
to be a CEO yeah rating is very high on
some level there's some kid in like the
Congo that is like digging up your Rare
Earth minerals and you have to look at
that and be like yeah you know what I'm
cool with that yeah you know right and I
I know I couldn't do that so yeah
there's a lot of people that all the
dirty work that gets done they just like
right but it's just the way it is so
that's easy so let's turn the tables
okay you talk about Rare Earth minerals
right like everything in this everything
in this right and then now now not only
that but we have two we made the
decision to go out and buy these okay as
an individual consumer and then the
individual consumer makes the decision
to download the the applications or the
individual parent allows the child to
download the application and allows that
consumption to happen and and so it's
it's that whole thing it's like well the
the cartel problem in Mexico would stop
if everyone in America just stopped
buying drugs
and and people for that matter well it's
like and it's true it would it would
there'd be no business to be made ah
it's so hard though because like right
now I think the only person I know that
doesn't have an iPhone is like Luke
LaFontaine he has a flip phone still I
have a Samsung okay no I meant our
smartphone I mean I'm just used to
iPhones being the only smartphone but
you also have to think like it's like I
think as consumers we decide to go
purchase these because we see the world
shifting in a way in which we feel like
we can't communicate correctly or
efficiently unless we have these
products we're a reliant species we
right you know what the word religion
means it actually means to bind together
that's what the etymology of that word
means and we survive by binding
ourselves together in groups and that's
how we've always survived and so of
course there's this inherent fear that
if you're not taking part in
the the way that people are
communicating around you you will die
which is a reasonable fear that's deeper
than just like whether or not you have a
smartphone that's that's that's that's
like what our brain structure is built
upon that's that brains that's that
reptile brain so it's super easy to
monopolize nowadays because this fear of
missing out and like keeping up with the
Joneses it's like we all if we're not
all like this you know if you ever if
you can't feel left behind anymore yeah
yeah I mean it's the same way when we
passed the when I when I when I took the
bar it was like we do we use the analogy
of a herd of cattle running through a
gate and you never want you never wanted
to be on the outside where you got
rubbed by the gate and you never wanted
to be first and you never wanted to be
last right but somebody somebody has to
be yeah yeah because that's the nature
of the game yeah and so yeah it was just
yeah I mean I I kind of Wonder like to
and this is an even larger question as
to what degree do we even have free will
in these areas
don't get Jake started on this I mean I
have not heard your thoughts on it but
I'll tell you from like my perspective a
little anecdote for for the group here
you know when I was in my mid-20s about
15 years ago when I was in my mid-20s I
did a lot of Roto work and with Roto
work I'm basically just clicking and
dragging all day long and I throw on
YouTube on the sidebar and I allow the
recommended feed to just run wild and
you know I I ended up watching like a
lot of political based videos and you
know I had very strong opinions on a lot
of different topics and I found myself
thinking about it all the time and I was
like I wanted to be ready for a debate
with people that I met and I wanted to
be able to engage in this thing that was
clearly such a big issue and I had such
strong opinions that I was so right
about and then the Roto work stopped and
I started doing a lot more work on set
and my time on set I wasn't looking at
YouTube at all I ended up going back to
doing Roto later started watching those
videos again and found that inherently I
disagreed with them after my time away
and I wonder to what degree I I noticed
that by accident
because my circumstances in life changed
and pulled me from the algorithm
and I thought I was immune I'm sure like
we all do to being manipulated in that
way yeah to what degree did I even have
any free will there because I didn't
know that I was binging I was just they
was just playing and I was just working
and I wasn't paying attention and it got
me and it pulled me into its vacuum and
I believed this thing and you know I
just wonder if if I hadn't accidentally
discovered that I was being fed this
stuff where would I be now and I
wouldn't even be aware that I was there
so you know when I look at all this
algorithm stuff I wonder to what degree
can we even be trusted to trust
ourselves
let alone trust a government let alone I
mean it just feels like no matter which
way you turn you're kind of ending up
yeah yeah it's it's like unless you
completely disassociate yourself from
social media or any type of mainstream
media there's someone who is holding
that power and there's there's an agenda
behind anything whether it's a good
agenda whether it's a bad agenda and me
and my mom are just talking about this
on the other day on the phone about race
and how you know this country has always
been it's keeping each other divided you
know whether we do it together with
government whatever but when you go on
social media there's always a post
whether it's you know black people not
liking white people or it's white people
not liking black people and then you
don't realize
oh now all of a sudden like I have these
thoughts of white people today are not
like or now I have those thoughts of
like this type of race or like girls do
this and like all men cheat it's you
know you just keep seeing all of this
stuff and now you have all these
opinions and there's like there's more
anger there's more hatred in your heart
you're like overly opinionated on stuff
that like doesn't even make sense all of
a sudden I think that was like a bigger
issue on Facebook I remember when like
in the political aspect everyone kept
getting all like bombarded with the
whole like Russia thing and Trump thing
people like why am I seeing this but now
everyone had an opinion everyone was
getting bombarded with with the
algorithm yeah and it's weird like
because the you know the idea of the
internet was like oh all the INF this
ocean of information is going to be
available to people and everybody will
be completely open-minded but it's like
I don't want to say the Opposites happen
because I think at least for myself like
kind of what you're talking about
as a like a person who I had the
internet from
I would have been
I don't know what would you guys say the
year is when like Google and everything
was like common use maybe like 2000 or
2005 2005 yeah yeah somewhere I would
have been I would have been young kids
so like I grew up my whole life was
being able to like
look up something immediately when
somebody like gave me their opinion or
stuff like that yeah
I felt like for me it opened my mind to
new ideas
but I can see how
also for people it and like actually as
I got older I think similar things
happen where it's like I believe things
because I saw it in a video and then
didn't question it more and then I kind
of ran with that for a few years but
um
yeah so I like the idea was that it
would open people up and it has kind of
closed people off into these little
things and it's really I was gonna say
it's really weird when you come across
people in the real world when they're
like like a q Anon person you know it's
like uh it's like they've ventured out
from their bunker yeah and but they're
just regular people like I you know my
parents lived in Florida for a short a
short period a few years ago and there
will just be normal ass people and
they'll be like uh and they'll just kind
of start leading you down this Alleyway
and they're like uh yeah so yeah you you
know
we've got the we got the drops yeah I
mean how many families have had that
thing where they've they've had to
disconnect from somebody because they're
just so deeply sucked into this
algorithm and just angry at the world
all the time and it's all that comes up
all the time I've had some friends who
that's happened to and it's like it's
devastating to see that yeah you know I
think do we blame I mean we blame social
media way too much for these problems
like we act as if it's the it's the
thing I don't think we blame ourselves
enough yeah I don't think I don't think
and I don't mean like Society I mean
look in the mirror
and and how do you how do you take take
social media out of the conversation for
a second how do you get better at
anything
but practice real life right and what is
what does that cause it causes you to
fail practice isn't is the inherent
process of trying something and failing
and then applying a new lesson learned
to the same process and trying something
and failing it's it's it's like
controlled pain it's it's this
controlled idea of like
putting yourself into a chaotic
situation
failing and then doing it again but each
time you do it the the walls the fog of
war recedes and you learn something more
I mean you learn something more I feel
like our ability to do that I mean we're
social animals yeah our ability to do
that is so like reliant on the people
that we have the community that we share
you know our support structures and like
what I was kind of getting is that I
think like we blame social media for
everything wrong is going on but I think
it's just because like our sense of
community is collapsing yeah with all
you know all of these things work
together to just sort of atomize people
into their little you know I mean you're
we're at the point now where you can
you can live your entire life from your
house you know you can order all your
food online you can do your job from
home uh you don't yeah you don't need
you don't even have to go to school in
person anymore like every time I call
someone for anything some Corporation
the girl today was like sorry my cat my
cat's meowing it's no one's in office
sorry yeah I was like I don't care but
you know like no one's in office like no
one's having like actual personal and
face issues anymore that you need to
talk about there's there's none of the
sense of community like you're saying is
completely gone like even the idea I
think that's like dinners and because I
think people are so excited about social
media and they were so now they got so
reliant on it because you can't fail on
social media you can
edit anything and you can repost and you
can take it down you can delete that
comment but like and so it's perfect and
it's much more easier I think that's
what's terrifying about the like the did
you guys see the whole metaverse like
reveal that they gave like last year
when they were like here's all the
aspects of the meta verse that we're
really excited about and Zuckerberg's
whole thing has been like this is about
like being able to socialize with anyone
anywhere right it's about 20 billion
they're not that excited about it right
now yeah it's very funny that they're
like if you ask him it's an investment
all right to think of people just like
disassociating even more is so scary
people this is what I mean about
individual choices though
when um a lot of this is a lot of this
is the result like Jordan your example
where you called somebody in customer
service and they were at home in their
cabinets mailing it's this is this is
the trade-off it's like you you get the
technology at your fingertips
and it comes insanely cheaply for what
it is
but in order for it to be cheap and
available it requires
effectively leave labor International
corporatization
of a particular thing to deliver a
particular service and the more we
and I I don't wanna again I don't want
to sound like like a a Luddite here or a
recluse but my point is just simply
if you don't take time to
to think about like what are my consume
consumption decisions
then you put yourself in a way in a way
where you just can continue to empower
the machine that is driving the whole
thing which is what you're saying Dean
about like the you know people losing
their sense of community and and that
comes with the fact that you're losing
your sense of community because you know
there's there's the thing that is
supplying the whatever it is you're
consuming at that time whether it be
like a conversation or a product or a
food is now being supplied to you
through some giant International chain
rather than something that was done in a
much more local level yeah and we're
doing that with consume we're doing that
with consumption and we're doing that
with the way that we like tell our
government what we want and we're and
and all these companies doing it you
said you know it kind of takes a certain
type of Quasi psychopath to run a major
corporation and because you have have to
look at that person in the eye who's
doing the labor to get the thing out
there and and we when we make those
decisions we we push that further and we
give it more power and and it has
brought certain freedoms to our lives
like you know communication and all
these easily readily available food and
clean water and like all these wonderful
things that we don't have to it's just
absolutely suffer through to get
but if we don't take any time to realize
what the possible other side of it is
then you know it's like we have to we
have to because that's our only choice
that's our only way forward
I guess hard yeah I mean
I kind of I'm kind of curious because
yeah on like a larger sense of but
that's where you grow it's pain sorry
yeah go ahead no no I get it but like in
in a larger sense you know that about a
phone is is I think a simple one where
you go hey I'm gonna buy this phone
what's the implication how is it made
like you can you can think about that
but I guess as far as you know just to
go back to to my anecdote for a second
the the implication of being manipulated
without being aware of it you know when
we talk about algorithms they feed you a
certain thing it's all about
click-through rate it's all about hey
what are you engaging with and you get
sucked into this thing that you're
oftentimes not even aware of so I'm kind
of curious for your thoughts on that
when you're talking about practice the
idea of practicing how do you practice
for something you don't even know you
need okay I'll put it this way have you
ever seen um
uh Dead Poet Society with Robin Williams
if you haven't seen it it's a great
drama it's one of his best performances
ever fantastic movie
um but anyway he has this scene
in it and he stands on top of a desk and
he's like guys stand on top of the desk
and all the students ask him why and he
says I'm standing on top of the desk to
Simply force myself to see the world in
a different way
and at the end when he you know I won't
spoil it but at the end it becomes like
the Montage of and the purpose for why
he was there which is to introduce this
idea into their life that you know 98 of
your life might be consistent and
routine but you need to consciously do
the two percent thing that puts you to
see the world in a different way and if
you don't do that you can't mutate and
grow
because you only see things in one way
and I guess my my thought on that is
just simply like we have to force
ourselves every now and then to stand on
top of the desk yeah you gotta go travel
you got to do you got to get yourself
out of your little box yeah yeah it's
like they go in the easy way every day
or literally it's like you're gonna take
the elevator you're gonna take the
stairs so we're gonna go to that
McDonald's that's on every corner are
you gonna go find the Ralph's to go
inside I thought you're gonna say are
you taking the 405 or the 101
yeah and I guess even with even with my
example you're you're totally right in
that you know if I'm consuming something
that is political then it is my due
diligence is I was about to say American
citizen but I'm not a citizen but as as
a permanent resident here in the in as a
global citizen as a global citizen
totally it's my responsibility to do my
due diligence for all sides of an
argument so I think that's very fair
yeah and this is why in the 60s they
wanted to put acid in the water supply
and that's right then the government was
like let's shut that down
that would have given everybody a little
bit of a different perspective
perspective
might have helped shut down the
military-industrial complex a little bit
and mandated mushroom water yeah
well you know people do that in uh South
America they go on Ayahuasca Journeys
yeah yeah you know because it's the same
thing yeah American Ayahuasca yeah and
now the whole Ayahuasca thing is being
turned into like a corporate Machine by
Americans it's like it's what we do best
man God damn it man it's like the thing
to do people go back on Monday they're
like sorry I was at Ayahuasca dude but
that's that's like why I don't wanna
that's why I don't wanna grow Corridor
like significantly Beyond just for
growth sake you know yeah because then
you just become that yeah it loses its
soul I think in the process yeah yeah
cause what what are you shooting for
like with growth you know well right
exactly why are you growing is anytime
something goes public really that's like
when hey our our main reason to exist
now is to grow for our that's right yeah
everything else the core of it is now
gone because it's public facing we are
investing to make money we're not
investing and honestly it's just a
corpse it's as simple as that yeah like
legit as soon as you start having more
people it's more problems you have
investors well now there's higher Stakes
Jalen can't do the stuff that he
normally does because now HR is involved
my name came up where are you going okay
foreign
yeah I don't know how we solved the the
legality of The Tick Tock band here but
I do should we just send this to them
it's in this convo over send it send it
over to Congress yeah yeah I know one
thing the audience can do and that you
can find at Corridor Digital on Tick
Tock and you can follow us for great
content
I didn't feel like the whole time we
were having this conversation somebody
was about to drop their like supplement
um yeah you can get 10 off with my code
okay
it is funny we do have a tick tock so we
are part of the whole yeah yeah okay so
let's let's look at ourselves in the
mirror for a second why do we have a
tick tock to keep up with the virus
growth is all that matters baby we have
a tick tock right because I because well
why don't you answer it Jordan why do we
have a tick tock well honestly I think
from day one we kept getting sent tick
tocks of our own content on Tick Tock
right like [__] it we're good we're
going to put our content first on Tick
Tock because sucks at copy because we
said if we don't if we don't Supply it
somebody else will yeah and that's
exactly what corporations do man yeah if
we know Jake the reason we have a tick
tock is because we're really excited
about the potentials of short form
content you know the ways to bring our
stories and our YouTube shorts have been
fun though
much cooler we have done some really fun
stupid ideas that we would have never
done it's true if we didn't have that
minute long platform it's the Goof
machine you can learn a lot of stuff on
tickle there are like something like
some videos like recipes whatever and I
don't mean to say that the whole
platform is like some you know from the
Devil Himself thing it's just yeah it's
it's like anything it's what it leads
you have overgrowths in the wrong areas
then it becomes something that's you
know not quite right yeah and it's also
you want to I mean I think here at World
War II we want to always be open to the
new things that are happening you don't
want to get stuck in your ways and yeah
you know totally only be making videos
for Facebook know like all these years
later like you know we tried to do
Facebook for a while but it didn't
didn't quite work out but yeah no that's
another thing that I do have a general I
guess concern and awareness of it's just
you know and that's I think another
reason why we chose to do it to do Tick
Tock it was just simply you know this
idea that hey we don't
you don't necessarily just want to be in
one place all the time yeah and it's
like with Tick Tock we're staying in the
loop the the Millennials are there so
it's like we're still there but if like
whoever needed to pull out of tick tock
our Brand's not gonna hurt like we're
not gonna be like wow that's why we
didn't yeah go go super hard into yeah
we don't go harder nobody makes money on
Tick Tock anyway not as yeah not as much
as we thought
yeah
oh one percent of people was just simply
this idea that
when you
um
create a platform and people start to
put things on there and the only thing
that you give them in exchange is quote
exposure
you know like what is the contract there
exactly yeah yeah I used to do that in
my early Instagram days
no more yeah yeah it's just like you're
just using me you're using anyone for
free right advertising advertising is
expensive yeah and that's what you start
to realize when you the more the better
you get at it right but like at first
and I think that's another reason why
it's been so prolific is because it it
has this ability to say like oh I put
out a video on Tick Tock and it like did
really well better than all the other
platforms I put it on I'm gonna and
that's it's that's the slot machine
design it's like you give them a little
bit you give them a little bit up front
and then they think you know then they
got hope and they keep pulling the lever
wait can I float a conspiracy theory
that's that's Tethered to that sure yeah
that's just the algorithm that they
design that's not a conspiracy theory
that's just
I have a conspiracy either God I'd like
to float what all right
forget everything you know about q no
I'm kidding no I think that with Tick
Tock and maybe this is just kind of a
variable of what you're saying I think
it gives everybody one video that pops
off pops off yes no yes totally true
conspiracy theory that's by Design top
influencer
it's like they're meant for those people
you know what I mean there's a bunch of
influencers that no matter what they
post it's going to do well yeah you
start a new account you start a new
account it gives you one wait the reason
I say conspiracy theory is because I
don't know that that's true I'm just
kind of seems consistent with almost
everybody no yeah because I have one of
them I have one that popped off well
beyond what anything else did but then
none of the other analytics made sense
it was just a ton of views and it
inspired me and I was like I found
something yeah Mama get the phone no I
know yeah there's a phone I'm gonna make
chili I know of people who that happened
to and they're like tick tocks my thing
now and they're like it's a bit they
think it's a business and they're trying
to they're trying to hit that first
thing and everything else is just
underperforming it's really I it has to
be designed because there's also the
aspect of it it's absolutely by Design I
can't prove it but like come on so it's
even just scrolling down the feed right
like the algorithm is good enough that
they could give you what you want every
time every time every now and then
though they give you something you don't
want because that's a slot machine
because the next one might be the best
video you've ever seen can I tell you
this can I tell you this can I be can I
be totally transparent for a moment yeah
get just really put my cards on the
table expose yes I used to watch Tick
Tock like I downloaded it and I got
semi-addicted and that's when I deleted
it forever this is a long time ago there
was one video that was six months ago
yeah yeah there was one video that was
like 30 seconds long and I just was in
the mood to like Let It play out and
let's see what happens and it's this
build up build up build up build up
build up and then at the end someone
farts and that's the end of the video
I'm like okay well anyway yeah fart
content nothing but far content because
guess what I did I watched a fart video
for 30 seconds and they're like this guy
likes farts you were watching it
ironically they have to have an
ironically button yeah say he's the fart
guy like and I'm like great this is all
I get now yeah and then you became a
fart and then I started to like it yeah
it's it's weird though like the
algorithm is like measuring how long
you're watching things weird they're
it's a good algorithm besides the fart
stuff I've purposely crafted my like
when I go you have your explore page on
Instagram and now it's like all Fitness
Post and like Rottweilers and some
fashion but like before there'd be you
know gossip wait why were Rottweilers I
love rottweilers
on Instagram Instagram knows you do yeah
and but as soon as you click on one
gossip like I will have to just I'll
look and try to not click it because
once you click it oh a gossip thing then
then you're in your explore page then
becomes that so you just you can't but
it's this weird like crafting of your
world you know I just I want to look at
Fitness I don't want to look at any
gossip columns because that's when you
just put the phone down people just put
it down get out in your backyard delete
the app
it's weird
it's that rabbit hole you click on one
and then Instagram's like
[Music]
but yeah I mean in summation for my part
I don't want to ban it just because
they're like oh do we want influence I
think JQ made a really good point and
I'm gonna think about that today the
idea of always rounding out your world
view like that's your responsibility and
I really like that well there's not much
time in the day everything needs
regularly yeah I'm just probably I'll
just start tomorrow
now where was I
into the podcast just looking at it no
literally the podcast will animal go
yeah all right thanks everybody
well anyway guys I really appreciate
y'all sharing your thoughts and having
this conversation it is informative to
help me sort of craft this uh this video
and I do want to do a lawyer explains on
on this so people can at least have
clear information about how this is
happening and what the implications are
um so yeah thanks for thanks for joining
us here and uh thanks for watching and
yeah thank you for blessing us with uh
that well-researched info you're welcome
sound is sarcastic yeah letting that
sound and sarcastic
videos
[Music]
all right thanks for watching everybody
have a great one
[Music]